demi lovato and noah cyrus enjoyed a fun
night out together
the two singers were photographed
holding hands while they attended the
space jam a new legacy
party in the park after dark event at
six flags magic mountain
at the event demi rocked a black beanie
a hot pink shirt and tie-dyed pants
while noah wore a white oversized
sweatshirt
jeans with patches and a navy beanie it
was a moment i had fun
the two have been spending a lot of time
together lately
demi and noah recently teamed up to
record a song titled easy for demi's
latest album
dancing with the devil the art of
starting over
their outing comes a week after the two
performed the collaboration for the
first time
during the youtube pride 2021 event the
artists were joined by the trans chorus
of los
angeles following their performance demi
shared a photo of the two
and thanked noah for joining them on
stage
demi captioned the snap thank you noah
cyrus for closing out the night with me
for youtube's pride 2021 celebration
i'm so happy we finally got to sing our
song together
the 21 year old singer then replied in
the comments section
thank you for having me you were
effortlessly perfect and
i'm never not in awe of you
[Music]
noah also posted a clip of their
performance on her instagram page
writing demi thank you for having me i'm
so proud of you and who you are
happy effing pride to all my lgbtq plus
brothers and sisters
you have my endless love and support
forever and always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
demi recently came out as non-binary and
in an interview with odyssey
they said their family has done an
incredible job with the pronoun usage
although their friends haven't adjusted
quite as easily
i've noticed especially my my older
sister
dallas um you know i've noticed
them i mean see i called her
i've noticed her using them and and they
and and it just it's it like really does
warm my heart up that that people
are trying and my friends have had like
a little harder time to get used to
actually
just because i think like your friends
are the ones that you're more likely to
be like [ __ ]
you know like you know and so
i'm like look you can still call me
[ __ ] back in 2016
demi was honored for being a longtime
advocate of the lgbtq plus community
at the glad awards and at the time they
opened up to e.t
about what advice they would give their
younger self on just
being themself i would tell my younger
self
love who you are i don't know why i'm
looking at the camera like you're
like me you're a little demi um love
yourself and you're beautiful
that's it and you're enough and i'm
enough there you go